I was surprised to find out that you
were inspired some of your activism
stemmed from this uh feeling you got
from your from your dad from his movies
from his movies right a number of years
ago one of Martin Luther King Yolanda
King Martin Luther one of his daughters
called me to talk about something or
other and I was in the process of
writing my Memoir and so I was curious
and I said to her Yolanda did your dad
Dr King did he you know like take you on
his lap and bounce you on his knees and
talk about values you know the kind of
values you and stuff like that
she said no we never did and I said yeah
my dad never did either
but you had your dad's sermons
and I had my dad's films he didn't
really need to say much you know I loved
him and admired him so much and I knew
that the movies like young Abe Lincoln
and Grapes of Wrath and 12 Angry Men and
wrong man those kind of movies were the
ones that he really loved and was proud
of doing and he loved those characters
those are the movies that I identified
with and it was like putting fertilizer
on my little soul when there was
something that triggered which for me
was the Vietnam War all of that became
fertile ground for activism your dad in
so many of his films and I'm thinking
specifically when he's in Grapes of
Wrath that speech he gives about the
little guy and that's me I'll be there
I'll be there that is that's a speech
that resonates maybe more now or at
least as much as it did during the Great
Depression you know there's a lot of
people out there that feel that they're
being bullied that they're being pushed
around and there's so many Henry Fonda
films where the core idea is you have to
stand up for the little guy trust us
fairness you know I never there were no
people of color around me when I was
growing up on on the west coast in
California but there was my father's
film The Oxbow incident which was about
a racist hanging you know that's yes
yeah it meant so much to me that's a
generation whether it's Dr King or Henry
Fonda or even my father people were not
raised
I don't think men were raised back then
to show a lot of emotion no they were so
told not to yeah well today still our
culture says you know if you want to be
a man you don't cry you don't express
need there's a wonderful movie it's one
of the nominated movies as best foreign
films it's called close I haven't seen
it it's about this issue of
boys in the beginning when they're young
they they love on each other they hug
each other they they sleep together they
cuddle they fall asleep on each other's
shoulders and so and then they start
going to a school you know they reach
adolescence and it's suddenly Are You
Are You Queer yeah kind of thing yeah
and they get ashamed and then they pull
back
and it's like a loss of humanity that
happens because of our culture that says
men aren't supposed to be vulnerable and
express emotions it's so sad I want to
you know part of what I want to do is
change that well I think you've done I
mean for example I thought it was
very brave was also artistically hugely
successful but and On Golden Pond you
and your father were laid bare in a
sense your struggle to connect and put
it on film for everybody to see and I
think when the movie came out as much as
I liked it I couldn't appreciate how
scary that is that's scarier to me than
jumping out of an airplane without a
parachute is is exposing that kind of
vulnerability with the parent because so
many people have a complicated
relationship with their parents
especially people of a certain age with
parents of a certain age especially if
the parents came from the Midwest yeah
and so was your dad aware the whole time
that that's what you were exploring or
could he tell himself well these are
just characters because they're just
characters oh okay there's a scene where
I tell him I want to be his friend it's
it's a scene where I I it's it's my big
scene in the movie every time I read it
in rehearsals I would become very
emotional because these are things that
I never said to my dad I want to be your
friend and then when it finally came
time for me to shoot to do it with the
camera facing me I dried up it was it
was really hard it was a really
important scene for me and my dad always
liked doing things that had been
rehearsed he wanted to know everything
that was going to happen in advance so
on purpose I did something that had I
hadn't done in rehearsal when I said I
want to be your friend I reached out and
touched his arm
and um
he ducked his head and he went like this
but I can see that he got emotional yeah
made me so happy and I went to dinner at
his house that night and um
I told him how I had dried up and and
how I had a hard time with the scene
because it was so personal I said you
know in your long career dad did that
ever happen to you nope yep that was it
Nope period nope yeah you know he didn't
say well tell me about what happened and
you know he had no
he had no clue nope but that's who he
was like yeah can't change it no well
you know it's funny you find out later
in therapy that that parents you know
they're doing what they can with what
they've been doing they're doing the
best they can they're doing the best
they can not all parents Sona I don't
think you're doing the best you can oh
okay sorry just to jump out for a second
well I've only been a parent for like a
year and a half but yeah you're saying
you're saying I'm already just you seem
high okay
that's not totally inaccurate those
first early years where you really have
to do the best you can oh okay then I
should stop getting the tie all the time